America is back and that we are coming
back bigger and better and stronger than
ever before and we're making our own
product again and we're opening up our
factories again at the center of
America's resurgence are the massive tax
cuts that I just signed into law and
it's also reformed but I usually just
say tax cuts because that's what people
would they don't want to hear about the
reform believe me the reform is very
important we don't have to go into it
but the tax cuts are the most
significant tax cut most significant
reform in American history with
tremendous tax relief for working
families for small businesses for big
businesses that produce jobs for just
about everybody tremendous numbers and
you're already seeing what's happening
Americans do anything build anything and
create anything as long as we have pride
in our country confidence in our values
and respect for our great American flag
because America doesn't belong to the
Washington powerbrokers it belongs to
you and I think we've taught them that
doesn't mean it's easy it doesn't mean
it's easy it's nasty in Washington but
step by step by step just keep going
right go and it is a nasty place whoo
but we're getting it nobody thought we
were gonna have this kind of success so
quickly America is back we have numbers
to prove it that was a President's
speech from earlier today in
Pennsylvania joining us now with
reaction Fox News contributor Tommy
Larry let me just read a little bit okay
2.2 million new jobs since the election
we've got Chrysler moving from Mexico to
Michigan that is huge and then of course
we have carrier and all these other
companies that we got massive tax cuts
which is going to benefit 90 plus
percent of Americans we got rid of all
this regulation 20 regulations gone for
every new one we have unemployment at an
18-year low applications for
unemployment at a forty five year low
black unemployment the lowest ever
recorded female unemployment the lowest
in 17 years
Hispanic unemployment the lowest ever
recorded that's like a half a century on
unemployment the Dow at 26,000 nearly
eight trillion dollars in new wealth to
the economy
oh I don't invest a whole lot in it
Apple returns to America with a massive
350 billion dollar investment and
there's many other companies how could
the media totally ignore this Tommy
Larry well because the Democrats and the
liberal mainstream media they're shaking
in their boots right now and it's
because President Trump is winning for
the American people that has been their
biggest fear since last year since he
was inaugurated on January 20th of last
year that has been their biggest fear
not that he was gonna bring this country
down that he was gonna make it great
again that's what he's doing and they
hate it that's why they're going crazy
literally going crazy the media the
Democrats Nancy Pelosi the whole lot of
them going crazy because this president
is winning just like it's like every
election the Republicans are racist
sexist homophobic Obama phobic you can't
really argue a whole lot with success
and my opinion that
all the noise we hear won't matter when
people are back to work
out of poverty off of food stamps and
the country is now prospering and we're
safe and secure because facts don't care
about their feelings and I'll tell you
this because I have been going out
you've been sending me out to West
Hollywood to other areas in California
which we think would be so liberal and
what I'm really finding out Shawn is
there are so many people that support
this president and they didn't support
him initially but they're seeing what
he's doing to benefit them and
everything turned around California hey
you know what they they want to make
money just as much as you and I do they
want to make money they want to keep
their hard-earned money
and they love this president they don't
like woody tweets they don't like what
he says that hurts their little feelings
but they like what he's doing for this
country and at the end of the day when
we come up to midterms we come to
re-election time that's what's going to
matter is the result and this president
is getting them what about all right so
the president comes out with this fake
news media Awards last night but then
you're watching the media and they're
trashing his doctor the guy that also is
the doctor Barack Obama George W Bush
and they're angry because the
president's in excellent health
how is anybody to interpret that other
than they just there's nothing this man
can do they'll ever like they want him
to fail and they want him to be ill and
they want him to die let's be honest
that's exactly what they want and they
are so frustrated that he's winning for
the America 30 he got a 30 out of 30 on
the cognitive test he's doing
wonderfully you know what we really
should do in the spirit of caring and
the spirit of sharing we should have
that same doctor examine folks like
Nancy Pelosi and Maxine Waters because
they need all the help they can get we
had dr. liberal Joe Scarborough and dr.
mica I want to see how well they do on
that test oh I would love to I think we
should share the doctors expertise with
those individuals because in the spirit
of mental health awareness they need far
more help than this president this
president is doing wonderfully he's like
he says he's a stable genius and you
know what I believe it because look at
this country we're doing great all of us
are doing great in the Democrat
terrified okay so you your obviously in
the younger generation do you see
younger people now liking what's
happening maybe people that are you know
Winston Churchill 20 not illiberal you
don't have a heart for tea and not
conservative you don't have a brain do
you see a change now I think that when
these young people are going out and
they're getting their first jobs you
know if they do move out of their
parents basement and actually want to
get a job they're gonna be happy when
they're able to keep more of what they
earn instead of sending it to Washington
DC for their favorite politicians I
think they're gonna start to see it and
this president gonna make a whole lot
more sense to them thanks Tommy we'll
see you next week